j'aimerais qu'on se tourne vers joachim
kim président des fois non pas là restés
clos est ce que c'est la mort des
forains toutes ces décisions oui ou non
laisser sur nous je t'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure tu dis on peut se déplacer oui
on l'a vécu à rouen moi j'étais avec des
participants endroits où manger gagnais
très bien ma vie à rouen bon d'accord
moi je suis partie droit j'ai abandonné
la foire je les fais deux années
d'affilée
j'ai pas payer mes frais je mange
comment j'ai une famille j'ai trois
enfants et j'ai deux manèges à crédit je
paye comment je fais quoi donc
la foire de rouen c'était 60 % de mon
chiffre de la sphère d'années c'était
une de mes meilleures fin de l'année on
may a fallu que je me retourne on a
refait notre big four n'est reparti dans
le midi on a changé de vie mais pourquoi
alors c'est ça doit toujours la
diffusion d'une version comme ça on les
délocalisations de tami et henjak me
fait la foire de rouen c'est la place
des jacobins ou rien ou vous proposer
une solution médiane alternative à log
on dit que vous avez des maires dans le
temps vous avez à monsieur comme xavier
bertrand dans sa vie mais il ya très
longtemps
il a accompagné la situation il a
dialogué avec les fromages
il a délocalisé mais il a mis les
services de deux voitures il a mis des
lavettes il a fait des affichages
publics
ils appellent ils à faire ce qu'il
fallait et ça marche très bien on entend
ce qui me gêne un peu c'est que c'est
souvent une habitude de mettre la
pression vous avez utilisé ce mot là
tout à l'heure on en novembre 2010 est
vous avez mis la pression sur la mairie
de paris en l'occurrence cette fois ci
en menaçant de bloquer tout paris parce
qu'on l'a foutu les langues
on vous avait retiré l'axé mais ça je
rejoins ce qu'a dit monsieur naulleau et
je reviens sur le mans parce que c'est
comme un exemple assez pratique c'est de
là qu'est parti le problème je le mans
ça a changé le monde a évolué vous avez
un tramway donc déjà de tramway permet
d'aller à en un quart d'heure jusqu'à on
le perd sur le terrain et quelle heure
je signe à une heure du matin à toute la
nuit
lors du matin tellement c'est papa foire
du trône a n'est pas dans une heure du
matin déjà cessé voilà à 2 2 c'est
facile de se stationner c'est quand même
fondamental en ville
3 vous managez hyper évolué et c'est
tant mieux pour nous parce qu'ils sont
plus molaires ils sont plus gros non ils
sont beaucoup plus gros souvent et
plus assuré évidemment sur 7 mètres
carrés sur 7000 m² et ben c'est plus
difficile de mettre des gros manèges à
sensations et puis le dernier point si
les nuisances sonores
alors je viens à tous ceux qui sont
d'accord il ya des réglages je tiens
quand est ce qu'un pion mais c'est une
évolution c'est à dire que le mont aussi
je suis devenue devenue rare c'est tout
ce que vous dites là paris avec des
grandes attractions et à l'époque le
dialogue à monter assez haut niveau
puisque le dialogue a été fait avec le
président français françois mitterrand
elle c'est lui qui nous a donné les
autorités à la scolarisation et c'est
une fois c'est une foire qui dure encore
maintenant qui a lieu deux mois
cette ville si tu sais oui nouvelle
installation il ya un cahier des charges
du fait que ce n'est pas gênant
marseille faisait bordry en place il ya
un gros malaise
s'il vous plaît si les chercheurs ont
établi au plus haut
j'aimerais rendre au camp de simone dans
le public vous parliez des nuisances
sonores justement simone elle est
riveraine hapoël et dérangé par une fête
foraine
il ya une fête foraine qui s'installe et
on bat ye et elle non plus
simonet si van persie au soir simone
parce que monsieur bayrou et après avoir
fait la place verdun à pau
je ne sais pas si vous vous y attendiez
ou si lui n'avait pas anticipé vous
savez que vous ne reviendrait plus
jamais place verdun qui a été transformé
en un beau parking arboré et c est donc
il ya beaucoup par katusha à londres et
que vous fait chamakh oui direz vous
alors allez-y c'est laisser parler
simmons simmons à lui le centre ville la
place verdun
vous savez que vous ne l'aurez jamais
plus donc il y à presqu'une heure deux
ans et demi et c'est ça ça vous méthode
vous dise des discrédite puisque c'est
par la violence aussi que vous avez fait
flancher monsieur bayrou en bloquant la
ville de pau mais si en brûlant des
pneus et bloquant l'autoroute les accès
à pau et j'entends des pierres en jetant
des pierres ce après un dialogue n'était
pas correct monsieur parce que
en tant que resort est bien dans les
gros chez moi nous avons vu nous vous
avons vu arriver sous nos balcons et
donc j'existe ou balcons sous-tend
d'alcon puisque si j'avais été souple
j'aurais sauté dans une navette
alors viens nous qui n'a pas été dit ici
du tout c'est le vivre ensemble
moi je ne veux absolument pas la mort du
monde forain bien sûr c'est dur a
toujours des enfants des jeunes des
logis peut-être même des moins jeunes
courent pour pour avoir envie de
s'amuser de cette façon là et vous avez
besoin de gagner votre vie et c'est
votre culture c'est votre c'est votre
bon de prendre votre corporation sais
pas je n'ai rien contre les
fourmillements bâtiment fait apparemment
non match et de santé mais apparaît d'un
parking et un beau parking on viendrait
java pour chaque sphère deviendront plus
puisque monsieur bayrou vous l'interdît
alors où nous allons l'interdît nous
avons subi face au préjudice de sonore
qui c'est votre milieu donc vous vous
êtes habitués au bruit c'est
insupportable je reconnais la réponse de
de joakim noah chi minh ville et fait
les nuisances sonores c'est vrai c'est
des solutions ah bon comment ça il ya
des gens qui crient continuer mais sur
un bateau pirate non non on a on a des
emplacements en place et cela va des
pirates en tournée à la fête à neuneu on
a tous les immeubles du 16e à bien vous
mangez des pommes d'amour là bas le
mange des pommes d'amour lui appartenait
pas une tête à manger des pommes d'amour
non non et on a des emplacements dans
des villes où les nuisances sonores sont
résorbés fait nos cinq sens strict les
riverains et si vous avez ce travail là
il faudra discuter que les foreurs a
laissé dire combien de gens vont dire
quelque chose m'a conseillé d'en vous
demande de vous des localisé à 10 km je
trouve ça inadmissible de localisation
proches
tenez là les casinos a pour bien senti
mal et s'était par beaumont est émis du
côté du zénith
les gens qui ont vraiment envie de jouer
ici
bon alors je suis rebondit sur je ne
sais plus qui a parlé des navettes
bien sûr qu'il faudrait que les maires
mettent des dés et y en a des solutions
à disposition dont je t'ai de vivre
ensemble ça serait trouvé une solution
bien sûr vous avez agents qui t'y pas
vraie profession mais en attend des
pensées aussi penser aussi que c'est
difficile je vous assure d'entendre
c'est votre gagne pain je le comprends
mais c'est très difficile de supporter
cette nuisance éthique du met qui met à
bout de nerfs est actuellement à pau où
maintenant les forains qui viennent à
pau acquisition en ce moment je crois
vont être reviennent en centre-ville pas
place verdun mais en face fondée à
nouveau le désespoir de des riverains
qui se demandent combien brescia ils
vont faire face qu'il deux là pour ça
qu'ils vont devenir ces par la russie
c'est que le maire